for the last couple of years I've been
curating my closet to develop a capsule
wardrobe that fits my lifestyle that
works well in all seasons and that has
color as a warm skin toned girl who is
also a girly girl at heart I love
dressing up and I love color but I found
that when I was first looking into how
to develop a capsule wardrobe or I
looked up capsule wardrobe tours most of
the videos I found were too bland and
neutral or they were from people who
live in warm climates that can get away
with crop tops and shorts all year long
I live in a for season climate last year
we had several consecutive days when the
temperatures remained below freezing
with a low of 1° f -7° c and we still
went about our business and went to
church and went grocery shopping and I
was able to stay warm and cozy while
wearing my favorite clothes so today let
me take you along for a fall and winter
capsule wardrobe tour with color for
Simplicity sake I've removed my
husband's clothes and everything that
you see here is my entire wardrobe that
and what's in a nightstand which I'll
show you in a moment but this is
basically summer fall winter and spring
I'm not going to go through each and
every single one of these pieces now but
maybe we'll do like a separate Spring
and Summer video and then we can talk
about some of those other pieces for my
layering pieces I have one cardigan and
two sweaters and they're all cropped for
one specific reason and that is that I
can easily take my summer clothes and
wear them for fall and winter I can wear
them with skirts with dresses with pants
to me these are definitely my layering
stap
and the rest of my clothes are in this
nightstand in the bottom drawer I keep
my undergarments my sports bras and my
sleepware and in the top drawer is where
I keep all of my pants my shorts and my
workout bottoms I have this very old
worn out pair of sweatpants that I could
probably get rid of however they're
still going strong I even painted with
them at one point but I don't really
mind the stains because this is
something that I'm actually not going to
have visible and I'm wanted to use what
I already have I also have a pair of
leggings that I use for working out out
and as a layering piece underneath my
dresses when it's not as cold but first
I want to share with you what it is that
I wore when it was below freezing for
several days and it's definitely these
sweatpants my usual black square neck
top that I'm sure you've seen in other
videos and then I basically wore a dress
over it this dress is actually one that
I snacked for $6 at a thrift store but I
loved it so much that I tried to search
for where it is that I could find
another one and I found it on Amazon and
I ended up buying another one in the
color pink because this is definitely
one that's super soft super comfortable
I can run around after my kids with it
it's machine washable and you can't tell
that I'm wearing sweatpants underneath
it because it has kind of like an empire
waist the way that it falls at the
waistline it really just you can't even
tell that I have sweatpants underneath
and if anything it probably makes me
look a little bit curvier than I
actually am which I don't really mind at
all this is the exact duplicate of the
orange dress except obviously it's in
the color pink but I love to wear these
two dresses for winter this is basically
what I lived in when it was below
freezing because I could layer on the
pieces you can't tell that I'm wearing
other layers underneath and I'm not too
hot when I'm indoors because it's a
light fabric but I feel like it also
kind of protects from the wind so that
it doesn't like hit my skin so much and
then I can also just remove The
Cardigans or sweaters or other jackets
and not be super hot either and I love
the cropped Cardigans and cropped
sweaters because they really accentuate
the waistline and they're just very
feminine and they really go well
together
as far as jackets this is where I may
not be the most stylish person but I
have a North Face rain jacket as kind of
like my makeshift trench coat I'm
certain that a trench coat would be much
more stylish but really I was going for
versatility I really wanted something
that I could wear in the summer that I
could wear for a rain that I could wear
in the winter and this to me is the
perfect mix the reason that it fits my
needs is because the type of material
that it has is makes it wind resist
resistant water resistant and I love
that I can cinch it at the waist so that
it still has a more feminine look while
maintaining its versatility I probably
should have mentioned this at the
beginning but I totally forgot I am not
sponsored by any of the companies that I
mentioned today or any of the companies
that sell any of the items that I
mention these are all things that I
purchased with my own money or that have
been given to me um by other people that
I know but no company has paid me or
gifted me anything to show you this
video so this is just me sharing the
clothes that I love and and that yeah I
love wearing my husband recently gifted
me the stress and cardigan from Lulu and
I absolutely love them both I love the
square neckline on the dress I love this
waistline I think it's very flattering
and I love that I can hide my sweatpants
underneath or leggings underneath and
then this cardigan is actually long I'm
5'7 so I have longer arms and I love
that they actually are long so if it's
not too cold I'll just layer them with
my rain jacket but if it gets super cold
then I pull out the big guns I have this
giant parka jacket that I've had for oh
my gosh at least 10 years it's
definitely been through a lot with me
and it's got stains at the arms that I
mean it might be embarrassing but hey I
am not about to be cold and I mean it's
still working it doesn't have any holes
in it so it's going to stay with me for
a while it may not be the most stylish
but when it is below freezing like you
know I I don't want to be cold but
enough of the super freezing days let me
show you some of the outfits that I wear
for fall one of the things that I do is
I wear these are definitely not spin
brand some Cheapo brand but I wear um
some shorts that are kind of tight
high-waisted underneath my dresses so
that I can be a little bit warmer if I
were summer then I just would go without
that but it kind of gives me an extra
layer so that I'm somewhat warm but not
too hot because fall can be hit or miss
here this dress and the next dress that
I'll share with you are from the brand
gray Cove and I am in love with them
they have pockets this the ties that
they have I can tie them in the front or
in the back and they're just a really
versatile item that I can wear in the
summer because it's linen so it's super
breathable and then I can also wear it
in the fall and just kind of dress it up
to be a little bit Cozier I can use them
with my cropped Cardigans and dress them
up with some booties and this is totally
me stealing my husband's socks because I
mean why buy my own socks when I can
just steal his the ankle boots that I
have are a pair that my husband bought
for me when he was in Mexico and I must
say he chose well because they have a
thick heel they're actually super
comfortable I could walk around them in
hours and the sole is kind of thick as
well so they're super comfortable but
they can really dress up an outfit
without compromising Comfort this next
dress is also from the brand grey Cove
it's also linen it also has pockets the
ties can also be tied either front or
back and again I am obsessed with the
square neckline so I thought that this
was adorable it just turned out to be
too short for me uh chasing after kids I
don't want accidental showing so it was
a little bit shorter than I usually like
to wear so I pair these with my
compression stockings from when I was a
nurse these are definitely a lot
sturdier and better than wearing like a
panty hose or leggings um but at the
same time they're good for my legs so
I'm may not be as stylish but hey I'm
comfortable and I've saved jeans for
last because actually what I wear the
least I don't know about you but I find
Jean shopping to be really difficult
after having two kids and fluctuating in
weight I found myself at the mall one
day trying to find a pair of jeans that
fit and I was there for hours trying on
so many different pairs and nothing
would fit me quite right and I just
settled on this particular one from a
apostel and it's not one that I can say
I'm in love with however it did fit me
at the waist it's a little bit shorter
for my likes because I usually wear tall
but I didn't have the budget to invest
in a brand like everlan or those kinds
of brands at the time so this is
probably what I'll just wear for a while
until it just won't go any further I
also want to share with you my third
jacket the other two that I have are
what I wear when I guess you could say
I'm kind of dressed up and this is what
I wear whenever I'm wearing jeans or
just casual outdoorsy stuff so if we're
Outdoors we're hiking we're having a
bonfire which we do often this is
usually what I wear I love this jacket
because the arms are actually fuzzy on
the inside I have yet to find very many
jackets that have fuzzy on the arms
usually it's just like your back in your
chest so I love that they put the detail
into that it's so cozy and they also
have like the arms that kind of protect
from the wind it is wind resistant water
resistant and I also love that it has
zippers on the pockets you might argue
that it's totally useless and pointless
but when you're working outside or doing
a workout or anything like that you
don't want stuff flying out of your
pockets so I've found it to be very
helpful I also love that it's form
fitted so that way it kind of protects
from the wind underneath and it just
overall makes it such a cozy jacket even
though it's very thin and compact
because I've had this for so many years
I don't even know if they actually still
sell it but uh if I can find it I'll
definitely link it down below in case
you're interested but again I'm not
sponsored I totally wish North Face
would sponsor me I love their stuff but
no not sponsored and as far as shoes
you've seen my ankle boots I will
sometimes wear them with jeans not often
generally if I'm doing anything outdoors
I will wear my Muk boots they're
basically a waterproof leather boot that
I use for hiking or anything outdoors
active wise where I want to protect my
feet and then usually for wearing jeans
anything casual I wear my pink berries I
like to have one kind of sneaker style
shoe and just wear them until they can't
go any further before I replace them so
this is my one pair for now and just so
you know I share the shoe rack with my
husband so if some of those look kind of
funny to you those are not my shoes so
that's it for this one guys and now I
have to put all of my husband's clothes
back where they belong I thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up and
subscribe so you won't miss when I post
a new video until next time bye for now